russia has announced large-scale naval
drills off the coast of ukraine
washington is pouring more forces and
weapons into eastern europe u.s
president joe biden has ordered an extra
3 000 u.s troops to the region in a
phone conference with other western
leaders he reaffirmed support for
ukrainian sovereignty biden also warning
american citizens to leave ukraine now
saying quote things could go crazy
quickly
more activity on all sides of the
ukraine conflict
russia's ministry of defense released
footage of navy ships arriving in
sevastopol bay on the black sea
in the russian annexed crimean peninsula
they're here taking part in large-scale
landing drills
the situation makes many ukrainians
uneasy
it's not a pleasant feeling
believe me
to
understand that you encircled
by the russian troops from belarus one
thousand kilometers more than one
thousand uh
from uh the east and the
last couple of
days russia actually closed the entire
azo sea and
the part of the black sea actually
accessed
the ukrainian ports to the black sea
the united states wants its citizens out
of harm's way immediately
president joe biden has urged all
americans to leave ukraine
if a russian attack on ukraine proceeds
it is likely to begin with aerial
bombing and missile attacks that could
obviously kill civilians without regard
to their nationality
a subsequent ground invasion would
involve the onslaught of a massive force
with virtually no notice communications
to arrange a departure could be severed
and commercial transit halted while
civilians pack up security forces are
coming in the other direction
around a thousand u.s soldiers arrived
in poland to add to the 4 000 service
members already stationed there
and on romania's black sea coast a
thousand strong strike force rolled in
from a u.s base in germany
nato's secretary general was there when
they arrived
he spoke of the importance of boots on
the ground as a deterrent to russia's
military buildup which he called
unjustified
so the combination of military buildup
threatening rhetoric and a track record
of using force against neighbors of
course that's the reason
for
being
seriously concerned
and
being vigilant and ready also to
[Music]
react if
they once again use force against
ukraine
although the u.s hasn't sent ground
forces to ukraine it continues to supply
weapons to the beleaguered country
part of a 200 million dollar security
package meant to keep this crisis from
escalating into an outright conflict
for some analysis tonight i'm joined by
richard zakwa he's a professor of
russian and european politics at the
university of kent in the uk he's the
author of several books including russia
against the rest the post cold war
crisis of world order professor it's
good to have you on the program
i'll ask you
we've we've asked a lot of people this
we're still trying to get a clear answer
do you know what what is vladimir
putin's end game
well the end game is the same one that
they've been trying to do for the last
30 years gorbachev yeltsin and putin and
that is to try to get a security order
on the continent which is what they
would call indivisible uh and inclusive
uh that in other words that nato isn't a
body as it were
excluding russia but it includes it uh
and so that goal isn't is quite clear
well how to achieve it though uh they
would argue look we made all our
speeches we had
put in speech in munich security
conference in 2007. we had medvedev's
ideas for a european security conference
announced actually in berlin in june
2008 we had in 2018 at his state of the
nation speech listen to us you know i'm
not saying that what they're doing is
justified or even that their demands
should all be accepted but what they are
saying is talk to us as equals don't
assume that you have justice and right
only on your side we have security
concerns of course it's not the most
delicate way of making this a this point
but certainly that's the point he's
trying to make and in fact these latest
maneuvers and so on it is finally in a
sense attempt to shock the west into a
genuine diplomatic process uh rather
than this of the tokens that have so far
been uh given so you say then amassing
these hundred thousand plus russian
soldiers in russia along the border with
ukraine
that's just that's more window dressing
to force
nato to force the west to come to the
table and to talk eye to eye
in part uh don't forget on the other
side that ukraine is 130 000 troops now
armed with british and american weapons
poised effectively if they sell wanted
i'm not saying they do to uh a season
attack the donbass so initially the
mobilization was to deter that the point
is my point is is that we are in this
sort of escalatory cycle and jen
stoltenberg clearly um ahead of nato
simply does not understand he's
completely out of his depth
uh but um blinken and sullivan don't
understand this the british of course
don't the germans i think did uh schultz
and others have understood and macro
understood that you cannot have a
security order against russia and not to
expect everything to continue smoothly
and they they say look it's been 30
years since the end of the cold war and
you know we've been complaining about
nato enlargement ever since you've
ignored us many many western
commentators uh george kennan the
leading one uh warned that there would
be a backlash now we're having a
backlash i'm not justifying it i'm
simply explaining it and and i wonder we
know that you're not going to get any of
putin's demands met in terms of um
bringing nato back to its
uh pre-9
size for example 97.
yes
but let's see 1997. let's let's assume
though that there could be an agreement
or an understanding reached regarding
ukraine ukraine
maintains its sovereignty but the west
the us
and russia have an understanding that
nato will not be in the picture in the
future of ukraine
is that possible
it's not just uh nato of course because
the united states has a you know it's
got 800 bases around the world and i'm
sure i'd like a few in ukraine so also
bilateral so it's got to be more than
simply a long-term
moratorium or nato expansion
but you know a genuine commitment to
neutrality which of course was the
official position until december 2014 on
and off uh in ukraine um and don't
forget this
there's the intersection of two major
crisis going on the one the internal
ukrainian one with two very different
models of state building one which
decides to build a state against russia
and with a security system also which
was ultimately uh i mean then i don't
think it was intended but it's excluded
russia and these two con
conflicts or crises are overlapping and
so our analysis must be clear that we've
got two things going on at the same time
professor stockway it's good to get your
analysis it's very valuable at this very
volatile time thank you
thank you
our washington bureau chief enos pole
she spoke to fiona hill a russia expert
and former u.s intelligence officer
given the warnings from the white house
how imminent is an invasion i think we
have to be vigilant at all times now i
mean the reason that the united states
was saying that it was imminent was to
make it very clear this could happen at
any time because of the nature and the
scale of the russian exercises
and that romania remember again that
russia invaded georgia at the tail end
of exercises because they've been
practicing for those kind of
contingencies and that's the danger that
we have now that there is a pretext
maybe you can give us kind of a
best-case scenario and a
worst-case scenario well the best in the
worst case scenario in some respects are
one in the same it's not just the
invasion it's that this you know the
invasion doesn't happen but we keep in
this tension on a more permanent basis
and that the whole idea
uh of security predictability
you know europol free and peace is gone
i mean basically putin is saying the
last 30 years where you know we
prospered uh on our terms
uh are unacceptable to russia and so
that whole idea of russia integrating
into europe in some fashion uh having
closer economic social and political
ties with europe is out the window and
that now we're facing uh an overtly
hostile russia that has also now joined
in with china because what we have seen
in the recent agreement with
uh president xi and putin in beijing is
that chinese telling the russians at the
very least we've got your back we don't
like nato or nato enlargement either we
certainly don't like the united states
not really specifically about europe as
a major market because for china that's
still important but the china and russia
are now very much tied together some say
some trump supporters obviously
say that with trump in office with his
trump's anti-nato course
putin would have kind of not
done what he did right now what do you
make of that putin would have seen the
united states as a very weak player
internationally
in uh
any event under president trump we saw a
lot of chaos on the domestic front but
uh president trump who was focused on
china and not about europe and he may
have thought that then well nobody's
watching ukraine nobody cares about
ukraine and i want to make sure that
ukraine is back in the fall the united
states is weak you know that have been
um a great deal of infighting in the
united states over trump staying in
power europe would have had a rift uh
with um basically the united states as
well uh let's talk about germany you
were pretty critical about uh the new
government
especially when it comes to the way they
are talking or not talking about
nordstrom 2.
this is kind of that diplomatic dance
you know you're on a tightrope and
you're trying not to go one way or
another i mean of course there is risk
for the german government of lawsuits
and all kinds of you know breaches of
contract that may um unfold from all of
this you've got to be very careful on
the domestic front you know under their
previous administration all the pressure
that was put on the german government
obviously was counterproductive i mean
you know we saw that
uh
president biden has tried to address
that by you know making this germany's
uh decision
you know but obviously we need to show a
complete unity and i think that
um somehow chancellor schultz managed to
thread that very difficult needle in
public of course
he didn't really say anything but he
also did not contradict president biden
when president biden said well we're
going to do this right and looked at him
chancellor schultz didn't didn't say
anything
and behind the scenes he seems to have
made it much more clear to members of
congress and the senate and other key
interlocutors here that germany is
considering this very seriously and
presumably
he will pass on that message to
president putin in person when he goes
to moscow unless of course we have some
invasion of ukraine beforehand which
might make that trip um difficult maybe
put that off
well let's look at the big picture with
alexi melnick who's co-director foreign
relations and international security
programs with the rusomkov center as a
think tank based in kiev welcome to dw
do you believe that russia is about to
invade ukraine
uh well we can we have different
opinions about about russia uh russia's
in canada or russia's plans
but there is there are certainly such
plans and there are certainly such such
intentions but it's going to happen and
money is going to happen it's a big
question
and so what is the end game then what
will success look like for president
putin in this conflict
well uh if you asked me the same
question like two or three months ago i
would say that the putting end game and
putting biggest objectives was ukrainian
independence to get ukraine as a
satellite to get the grain in the sphere
of influence
but
after his uh
ultimatum sent to nato and the united
states and regarding the latest
statement it seems like now he is he has
much bigger ambitions he wants to be
respected he wants to be hurt but
unfortunately his demands are simply are
not acceptable by the way so it's a big
geopolitical game and ukraine
unfortunately is in the ep center for
that game okay nato is providing uh
reassurance to its eastern members by
bolstering troop numbers there but what
do you think the alliance will actually
do if russia does invade
well certainly
the alliance will keep
supporting ukraine
on political
diplomatic and even military technical
level
but
also certainly alliance is not going to
send boots on the ground
and what is more important ukrainian
authorities has never asked
for soldiers
so we are we have plenty of manpower we
have very strong mood we have a very
high level of readiness to defend the
country
but
we
do need the international support
right and
you talk about ukraine being ready it
obviously it's going to be outgunned by
russia um
can they actually defend their country
well uh the aim of uh ukrainian defense
reforms which were
been in progress since 20 at least 2016
uh is not to reach the military balance
or
similar to what russia has
our aim is
mostly defense and deterrence to the
price for possible any possible russian
invasion to the level that this cost
benefit calculate to change the
kremlin's cost benefit calculations
right it if they invade it has to cost
them daily because russia now has about
130 000 troops at ukraine's border there
are war games going on in neighboring
belarus and now naval drills in the
black sea effectively blocking ukraine's
ports so as you see this unfold are you
actually worried
well
it's not a pleasant feeling uh believe
me
to
understand that you encircled
by the russian troops from belarus 1000
kilometers more than 1000
from the east and the
last couple of days
russia actually closed the entire azo
sea and
the part of the black sea actually
access
for ukrainian ports to the black sea and
you you can understand that this is not
very pleasant feeling at the same time i
live in kiev i haven't noticed anything
unusual either on the street on the
supermarkets on in conversation in my
with my friends and colleagues right so
that's
when the choppers looks like right like
rather calm but
again
it is something that you
really feel if not even thinking about
understood life goes on alexi melnick
from the razomkov center thank you so
much
you